[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
青山学院大学1年生の生島力と申します
まずこんなようなあの舞台に出るということを自分を信じられておりません
ありがとうございます
さてっ
僕は
自分で隠れた自由というものをかけた中という新しいアイデアを考えました
そして皆さんに今日伝えしたいのは隠れた自由を見つけようというお話でございます
突然ですが最近このような会話が多いです
年上の方との壁ならですか
生島君南紗彩えっ18歳大学生か
大学でいいじゃん自由で遊べていいじゃん
言われるのですが僕はいつもそんなに中ではないと思いますよと言います
1このような会話を電車の中で思い出しました
本当に中じゃないなぁ横見ても近くにサラリーマンの方へれている
こんなにもぎゅうぎゅうづめでもう前見ても打ち返してもう全然自由じゃない
心も中じゃないし実際に見ても自由じゃないと思ったんですよ
疲れたと思って上みたら
意外と思う
柔軟じゃねえと思いました
それはこちらです
上の空間転移も開いてません
いう横二重爪でも実は上を見たら空いている空間がありました
あ意外と見落としている自由ってあるんだな僕は今電車位の手で自由じゃないなって
思ったんですけど
上見たらあ
10なんかもしれないと
得ることができました
話を変えます
僕の自由なイメージを絵に表してみます自由というのは様々な選択肢があって
複数の選択肢がありません
多くの人は今はこの全ての選択肢を選べると思ってしまうのですが実際はそうではあり
ません
こちらです
たくさんの選択肢がある中で自分が今見えている自由と見えていない隠れた自由がある
のだということを僕はお伝えしたいです
見える中というのはシンプルに捉えた場合の中ですねいわゆる自由っていうものです
あ自由がないが中になりたいというときは入ってこちらです
出雲な中といいなんですが今日はあえて区別するために見える自由とお伝えさせて
いただきます
私たちは自由である時はいいのですがいつも ga であるとは限りますよね先ほどの
電車のように
電車の時に
ベン社の時に周りを見て
きついが自由がないなーって思うのはこちらの話です
見える自由がないなと思っております
これは見える自由が減ってしまうということなんですかしかし少し視点を変えるだけ
少し視点を変えるだけで
上には空間があるまだ自由な部分あるじゃんと思います
私を取り巻いている状況が窮屈
普通辛いといった時に多くの人は
銃がなくなったら解釈していますがこれは本当にもったいないことなのです
このような例を通して
隠れた獣というのは新たな自由ではなく
私たちが気づいていないは事実がは私たちが気付いてないけれども実は持っている樹
視点を変えるだけです前から後ろ向くだけで気づくかけた中というものがあります
まずは学校生活における隠れた獣についてお話しさせていただきたいなと思います
抱えた12可能
学生生活の隠れた獣
腕を上げさせていただきます
wc 学園という学校があったとします
女性は赤のシャツ赤のスカート
で服です真っ赤ですあ
男性は青のシャツ青のズボ
でも反戦とはこちらです
今日はこれを正当だと思ってくださいあくまで生徒ですもう帆船とですから
で生徒
2パターンに分かれます
vierge つまり自由がないお菜家がー
こう言って反抗して
出航きたり
髪を染めたりする人です
でもう一度パターンというのは隠れた自由があると捉える人です
な人は
服のこと
確かにやらケロ
そこで反抗するよりは
内面を輝かせたい何面を輝かせる自由というのはいくら服が制限されてもあるという
ことに気づきました
例えば
サッカーに没頭したり本を読んだりして
自分なりの方法で限られた中でも自分なりの方法で輝こうとします
そしてそれは自分の話をいたしたいと思います
僕は高校生の時に水泳部に入っていました
dm 高校2年生になって
下から数えたほうがいい成績なのにも関わらず早くもないし
力もないし
ね説得力もないのですが部長にヤバイましたん
さてこれはどうしよう困った
全然言うことを聞いてもらえないし
僕も自信ないし
た人の上に立っておい
動けというのも
難しいし合わないなと思っていましたしかし
僕はそんな中で隠れた獣というものをあるし見つけました
どのようにまとめてもいい
いいという自由です
自分に合った方法でやればいいという子です
僕はもともと命令する料理は話を聞いて
ほどねといって理解してもらう方が気持ち的にも楽でしたのでその方向で一人一人と
向き合って
まとめていけばいいのかなという方向でやったらそっちのがうまくいきましたし
皆さんにとっても良かったのです
このように
もちろん
どう見てもきついことがありましても
実はその中に隠れた獣があってそれを活かすことで意外な感が導き出すことができる
自由でないのではなくて潜んでいる自由つまり隠れた自由があるのだということを
共有したいなと思います
つまり
自由でないと考えるの隠れた獣があると考え直すことです
くれた子はあるかもしれない
最近ですねー
僕たち
くれた自由が見えなくなってきているのだと思います
特にもともと日本人というのは隠れた自由を最大限に生かす
隠れた自由も名亡くなった子も最大限に生かす
ものでしたしかし最近はできなくなっています
左にどういうことがお話ししたいと思います
日本の全党的な詩や歌ですね3
バイクあります
どれも後7号77号7号といったように非常に限られている形式です
しかしはい人や華人というのはその中にある最大限の地形を生かして
素晴らしい作品を世に送り出してとてもたくさんの人の心を動かしています
これは今の時代になったら決して生まれなかったものだと思います
もう一つの例ですねになめこもそうだと思います
嫁今後日本語昔からある伝統的な遊びですが顔の実を使って相手の勝負をして楽しみ
ます
体を使わずに言葉も使わずに顔立ちを使って楽しむ
これも
最近
いくら素晴らしいゲームクリエイターでも作ることができなかったのではないかと思い
ます
猫ちゃ
昔の日本がの人々が今を生きる私たちに比べ
見える自由や隠れた自由にかかわらず
今もっている銃を最大限に生かせたしかし
は私たちは昔よりもん
これは昔の人ですねぐるぐる回ってミール g は薄利だジャンジャネル地
たし今のところです選択肢がいっぱい増えました
どんどんどんどん新しい g を求めていきます例えばよく
私たち
僕はですが
海外に関して買いっ
関心があることが多いです
以下の企業というのは大きくて
世界の中心である上
エリカの大学もさらに高いクオリティの教育が起きることができる
さらに他の国での進行の人たちを助けたいと思ってボランティア活動を行ったりします
もちろんこれ本当にとっても大切なことだと思いますが
それを見ていると
日本のことについての関心がなくなってきてしまっているのではないかなと思います
これは僕が思うことなのですが
やはりあの英語を勉強しなければいけないいけないと思うのですが
日本のお寺のことを全然知らなかったり
世界遺産へそんなのあるぞ
いうようなことが起きてしまいます
別の例を紹介したいと思います
インターネットが普及しました
パソコンやスマートフォンも
ました
すると電車の中でも電車の中で立ちながらでも地球の裏側にいる人と
コミュニケーションをとることができます
しかしそれによって電車で隣にいる人や前にいるひとまわりの景色などに関する関心は
薄れてしまいました
もちろん本当に便利なツールですが
これらが
隠れた中に気付きにくくなったこんなにあるんでしょうかくれた中に
なった
な原因だと思います
社会海外に目を向けることや情報が増えることによって
名なくなってきているのではないかなと思います
そんな中でじゃあどうやって隠れた獣を見つければいいのかということなのですが一つ
相手はございますそれを共有したいと思います
日帰りで一人旅をするというものです
市は決まっていません
時間は決まっていません
持ち物はお金少しの音階交通費0電車に乗ったりバスに乗ったりすることでどこが
決まってないけれどその中でうまくやっていこう
とする最低限のものですスマートフォン地図一切持ちません
僕も実際にこれをやったことがあります
思い立ってそうだ
電車で1時間半くらいかけた a
北神奈川県に住んでるのですが埼玉県のあるところに行って
沢山の隠れた獣を得ることができましたその電車に乗っている時も
今まで人の後フォンや本を読んでいることによって見つからなかった
あ
こんな影響あったんだこんな景色あったんだこんなお店あったんだという発見をする
ことができましたが
おっ
他にもたっくさんのたくさんの隠れた獣を見つけることができました
たった1日こんな反日でもいいから
一人旅
スマートフォン地図を持たない
misery 電車に乗ったりバスに乗ったり出することができても
いいのでぜひ1何も半日でもいいので行ってみてはいかがでしょうか
さて隠れた143月を撮るお話をしましたがまだまだ私たちの周りには隠れた獣が潜ん
でいます
付ければ以外の可能性に気づき驚くべき結果をもたらすことがあります
窮屈ある自由でない
じゃないと思った時に
あーもう
なのかな
お年を落ち込むのではなく
隠れた獣はあるかもしれないと考えを変えるだけです
隠れた自由があるかもしれないと考えを変えるだけで
よくなることがあります
皆さんにこのアイデアを提案したいと思いますご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]